your body seems so rock-hard do you
think you could like grate cheese on it
or like crack an egg on there not sure
never thought about it like that but a
good question
what about - I mean joshan's house and
lets get ready to rhumble it's Michael B
Jordan what I loved about this film and
why fought was so good it shows like the
fragility of masculinity behind the
muscles how important do you think this
portrayal of masculinity is in 2018
would you say I think the super
important um show layers show that she
could be physical in masculine but the
same time be vulnerable and emotional as
well I think Adonis is a very emotional
character a very emotional person and
he's selfish throughout this film for a
little bit but with understanding and
becoming a father and other obstacles
and things thrown his way he's humbled
and also he's allowed to grow throughout
this movie say when you were like
training for this obviously it's very
intense everyone's gonna be talking
about how intense the workout was what's
the most extreme excuse you've ever used
the girl going to the gym surely you've
used one maybe like some stomach
problems or something yeah I've kind of
I went there it's like that mean girls
like I also really think is a really
impossible
is potestas character is a very
well-rounded girlfriend character and I
was just talking to her about this and
we were saying isn't it crazy that every
single interview will come in and be
like what's it like to play like a
powerful well-rounded girlfriend world
and I want to put you what's it like
playing a powerful boyfriend role
Tessa's heckling me even while she's not
here she's it feels it feels good it
feels good
feels great it was great this is the
most important thing and as well like
your confidence I feel like should be
like packaged and like sold on to the
mass market you like is it well if you
were gonna but all the michael fragrance
room what would you call there and how
would you pitch it in like a department
store but yeah i don't know the pegs you
know just whose yeah yeah how would you
pitch it just oops oh that's it
glow by j.lo me vapor we're getting this
happening and also the pep talks in this
alike a thing on another another level
it is what would be the ultimate pep
talk that you could get me but I'm
having a bit of a down day down to a man
just like even it you good you know
believe in things that you want to
achieve you can do you know you gotta
focus work hard you know I mean and
dedicate yourself to the cause and you
will be successful I feel motivated oh
babe I feel might faint being in the
room with you after this was like I need
to get down that chair if you're gonna
create your own kind of like Barry's
boot camp
select the night Michael B cam how
intense would you make it and what would
we do
it'll be stages you know you have the
leg in to interview to get to the next
level you got to complete this one
because no matter you can't just like
throw somebody into the deep end and
expect them to actually like Billy
because you want to give them small
successes yeah to equal to the big you
know it's gonna get to the big victory I
would be doing I don't know man you know
lifting weights a little bit of cardio
there's some swimming mix it up a little
bit keep things fresh I feel like I'm
nervous already for this trading session
and what I also love is about how you
make the ultimate entrances in this like
what would your top tips be for making
the ultimate and trim I don't know man I
mean I feel like everybody needs their
own theme music so I think it's um good
theme song or intro song I think that's
one way to definitely get things started
because everybody I hear you before the
sea and then when you walk in it's just
like the tables already set people
already expecting they're already in a
mood
because they heard the song already yeah
something like that I like that I think
just need the confidence the swagger I
think you gotta believe yourself I also
just really loved how cheeky Chrissy
Teigen was with you the other day which
is like a malignant your Deann yeah I
bet after this you've had so many people
being like you're a knockout
think think histogram broke think master
game broke after that and you're amazing
keep doing what you're doing and you
keep slaying seven up there hunches it's
a knockout sin graduation mommy
[Music]